you know I left something in another
room um excuse me everyone
still has the sensors on I was like him
in his room yeah
yeah
what is he is he is he on his knees does
he drop to his knee oh no no no he's
probably looking for no look he's he's
crying he's crying oh no he's just
he's shattering is he fetal yeah he
curled up look at that he's fetal hey
Craig buddy you all right up there oh
yeah Mom I'm coming right out
uh greetings adventurers great things
as you all can see here we have a new
traveler in our ranks uh this is my
cousin Tyrell and he will be controlling
the player character
his name is Kanye
he's a giant yo
uh dear cousin traditionally uh ajai
does not assumed by a player it is a
chaotic evil but I want to be a giant yo
are big
oh okay fine well Travelers you are
enjoyed on your adventure today by a
giant named Kanye
now when last we left you you were at
the Inn of the North Star in the town of
isildor how do you begin your adventure
I want to get some [__]
wear the club at Isador yeah Tyro This
is highly unusual I think the guys
probably just want to go on the quest
David yes I'd like to join Kanye the
giant of this Quest
seriously
all right the two of you enter it's
Heaven what do you say Kanye the giant
orders Alize hmm is the barkeep I know
not of this foreign beverage of which
you speak perhaps you'd enjoy an eldered
ale no we both want the LSA I would say
does not exist in this world Kanye the
giant slaps that [__] oh Katie the
giant attempts to slap the bartender
here the bartender is half Hobbit and
very Nimble so you're going to have to
roll it 18 or above to hit 20. flip slap
that Hobbit off yo okay
follow the cleric would you care to
restrain Katya the giant before the town
guard is called I grab money out of the
register
Ed the cleric is lawful good
thievery would dishonor his Gods amen
the only guys is money and [__] dude
except Kanye the Giants gods and uh
I steal some of the money too
okay would you now like to continue your
quest for the leads of caldahar fellas
we came here for [__] where the
[__] at
all right you see a bevy of well-endowed
wedges great
I grabbed them [__] and we all go on
my SUV fine Heidi the giant udar the
dwarf and Gollum the cleric climb into
his SUV with their [__] and their
ill-gotten gains
plus Kanye the giant puts his demo CD in
the season no he doesn't there are those
CDs
do whatever you want
I I guess I'm the dungeon master now
the eye of Odin opens up
[Applause]
16 titties fall out yes
so you can say as much as you want
we can't say the name of the celebrity
or any part of their name got it yeah
yeah we got it we got it
and go
okay this guy E equals MC squared Albert
Einstein yes that is correct that's easy
hello okay this is this is the uh
determinator oh Arnold Schwarzenegger we
got uh let me talk about uh uh are you
talking to me
[Applause]
pretend to be straight but he's really
gay
uh uh he is um excuse me he's living
live in La Vida Loca
you say um
Latin Pop Star
I'm not a Latin Pop Star no you're not
it's not you
he bangs he bangs oh Ricky Martin
that is correct I wrote that one too
and then Tyrell about to come out here
right now you're gonna watch that lady
what's this what she's doing yo Tyrell
y'all what up Lauren hey man you wanna
play front hand back here I don't know
that game man it's easy dawg all you
gotta do is stay front hand the backhand
backhand
[Laughter]
huh it's still my move right I choose
backhand this time
really back hand
s
yeah oh look I'm sorry but I ain't sorry
you know what I mean I mean you asked
for it I mean you literally had asked
for it
right hand what no why you wanna hit him
got it got it I figured it out front
hand no backhand backhand no look look
dude hey if you want me to slap you
across the face back hand I'll do it
okay don't think I won't do it but but
you know that I'm [__] with you right I
mean there ain't no game called front
hand backhand
oh oh
not yeah I get it I get it all right all
right all right as soon as I get good at
front hand back hand You Wanna Stop
playing play what man I made it up so I
can smack you in the face I'm all about
to smack you in the face
as soon as it's my turn right hand there
ain't no terms cause it ain't no game
you ain't got no game
right hand
no I don't know if you [__] with me
at this point or what
but I don't wanna
smacking no more
where you going then okay forfeit
forfeit I win I win in front of him back
again okay me and you me and you me and
you
huh backhand
oh God what that's amazing amazing I
know look at your voice
[Music]
[Applause]
dude you have absolutely mastered this
game well since um Sheila left I've been
spending a lot of time here we go
playing the game you're doing really
good thank you that's why we're here man
help you get over her and check out this
awesome new game you have
you know I left something in another
room um excuse me everyone
still has the sensors on
I was like him in his room yeah you can
see him that's funny what is he doing
is he is he on his knees does he drop to
his knee oh no no no he's probably
looking for no look he's he's crying
he's crying oh no he's just
he's shattering is he fetal yeah he
curled up look at that he's fetal hey
Craig buddy you all right up there oh
yeah Mom I'm coming right out
[Music]
okay
um
hey man you all right yes yeah oh yeah
yeah it's just my sinuses are acting up
yeah yeah I um I was just you know I was
just thinking about Sheila and you know
what I am I am totally over her awesome
awesome that's hey let's get this party
started sure oh
uh
I forgot to get rid of this picture
Sheila excuse me hey maybe leave the
sensor so one of us can play
saying he's dancing with a photo is he
he's doing he's doing this about it is
he kissing you guys I think he's kissing
it you know what I'm gonna turn this off
because we don't need to change it and
you die
he's entering his Buckle look at this
his pants are coming off his pants are
coming off oh God
yeah no no no no no no no no no no okay
that's happened oh no no no is he he's
he is totally on the bed he's totally
flat on the bed oh maybe he's shaking a
can of hairspray oh God
we shouldn't be okay you know is he
reaching down for his foot I know that's
his foot isn't it
and coming back
[Music]
I am sorry everybody
would you like me to make some snacks
wash your hands first
[Music]